some of his opening work secrets
so we have seen him actually switch
things up and play the english played
loretti
but uh you know if they played a queen's
gambit before who knows
and if it is queen's gambit what are the
opening we're looking for so we will
look for white pushing his queen's pawn
forward and maybe black doing the same
okay this knight move is still flexible
we could transpose into the queen's
gambit okay we haven't though it's the
grunfeld defense so no more queens
gambit uh black has pushed a pawn on the
wing the g pawn and that means he's
going to put the black dark square
bishop now on the long diagonal so uh
not queen's gambit anymore but one of my
favorite openings and it's actually a
bunch of quick moves a set of knights
and pawns leaving the board it's
actually the exchange variation of the
grenfell defense so chester ball there
is a great course by peter svidler maybe
the kind of leading grenfell expert in
chess history and uh yeah i've studied
that course in a lot of detail because
this is one of the critical lines
white has a great pawn center but black
trying to chip away at that center from
afar the black queen on a nice diagonal
with the black dark square bishop on a
nice diagonal as well and simon you've
had some experience here too
yeah i i've never played the black side
of this opening i again i think i've
mentioned before how i like having the
center uh traditionally so i like
playing white normally in these
positions having those two strong pawns
i remember i think there was a lot of
kramnik games kramnik used to play this
as white this particular system yeah
i remember kramnik was just often would
swap the queens off and win a beautiful
ending but they're certainly following
uh theory at the moment with this
annoying bishop move uh asking the
question
funny simon actually until this last
rook move that i've had that exact
position against kramnik himself oh wow
he destroyed me so wow okay
if you're looking to learn this position
on the white side vladimir kramnik's
games
i was going to ask you the question
because when i saw this particular
opening for black i was a bit shocked
because
i haven't really seen mama jaro have
played the grunfeld i've seen him play a
lot of queen's gambit declines the
sharpest variations there
but this
doesn't kind of suit his philosophy
right he kind of is a bit of a renegade
he goes you know he but he uh marches to
his own drama and creates fiery ideas
from nowhere yeah i mean he has played
the grunfeld at least in the past uh
maybe when he was a lot younger quite a
lot but these days he doesn't want to go
down the main lines he doesn't really
want to go enter all these forcing
forcing variations where it's just a
memory test he wants to be creative so
you're right there ivanka maybe mama
jaroff was trying to play mind games
with ding maybe he assumed ding wouldn't
go into one of the main lines because
with he's got the candidates on the
horizon but this is one of the uh most
critical variations so maybe he's doing
roger for favor but i don't think rajab
plays the groomfield uh rajabov used to
play the graphics
okay and with white rajabov often plays
1d4 so maybe he's helping his countrymen
out you know he's kind of saying hey
ahead of the candidates next month where
rajabov will be playing that's
interesting
yeah okay i'm going to be looking out
next month in june
rajabov against ding is it going to be a
grunfeld is he going to learn something
from this game and
meanwhile look at that white pawn on the
d6 square so far advanced now that pawn
is either very very strong or it's a
weakness and it might drop off the board
later
so uh the evaluation bar let's
keep an eye off that for now let's
ignore it because when i analyze these
positions with a computer they always
say white's got a bit of an advantage
but actually it can change completely in
one move
and uh simon i know what you would love
to do in this position yes again i mean
it's always me pushing this pawn isn't
it but
it's uh
yeah do you want to push it do you want
to suggest it uh do you want to have a
go
i'm very happy to pass over harry tube
today um i mean
in general it's just a very normal move
in the green field when you've
it works a lot better when you've
controlled the center of the board so
here i'd say white does have good
control and center especially with this
thorn of a d pawn right in the middle of
black's position and if you control the
center you can do more uh outrageous or
aggressive ideas on the wings so um the
move played it is is also
very standard trying to get rid of the
defender of black's king let's say that
bishop retreats into the corner uh
trying to keep the bishop to defend the
black king now we can certainly consider
launching the h pawn
and this just has the one idea of
opening up the h file for the rook
bringing the queen in later on
checkmating and wow this this would seem
like a very normal way to play winter
just to show some moves after a trade
here all you need to do is somehow
evacuate this square bring the white
queen in later and wow we could be
heading in this direction um there's
always flashy ideas such as moving this
bishop and then getting the queen in
look at this open line as well towards
the black king it's almost checkmate in
a lot of these variations i've been
checkmated myself dozens of kinds of
here it comes
this is called the harry attack right
the reason i ask this is because we have
a nice tweet from turkey who said he
says that their goal in chess is to
[Music]
just remember everyone at home this is
most effective i mean it's always
effective pushing the h1 but it's most
effective when your opponent has this
structure um this triangle because then
with your pawn push you can chip away
and erode that structure very very sorry
dave i was going to say it's very brave
of mama jarov to play play this way i
don't think it's so brave for ding to
play as white this because this is quite
a common idea but for majora to play
this he wants to he was not typical mama
draft in a lot of ways he's trying to
unbalance the position uh with the black
pieces so by by now getting some counter
play but yeah it looks like he's playing
on the wrong side of the board he wants
to push this pawn black maybe he wants
to develop his bishop to this square hit
white center but surely the action is
taking place around the black king it's
just going to be a race here in in a way
white's attack against black's kind of
threats on the other flank uh on the
other side of the board but
yeah as i mentioned i have lost too many
painful games myself on the black side
of this type of position i would be
terrified especially with an attacker
like ding coming at my king
so uh
maybe it's worth showing just one nice
pattern how you can try to checkmate
with a rook bishop queen and porn
i mean i'm not going to play very good
moves for black but i've seen some great
games especially john none doing this
tactic and let's say uh knight b6 is h5
yep knight b6
and i think h5 has been played you take
on g6
and now black takes with the h pawn
otherwise is structured bad and there's
a lovely move here bishop f8 which uh i
i don't know if it works here but this
kind of idea is one of the beautiful
ways you can try to attack it's it's
useful knowing these uh attacking
strategies when you're playing this way
so so you automatically know the right
ideas and if that bishop is taken the
queen will will dive in so it's these
little ideas and we could even for
example it doesn't work as well in the
actual game because black's knight
defends the bishop from coming in and i
expect black has to take the other pawn
here it looks far too scary surely to
take the h pawn i mean you can't take
the h pawn here can you no just to show
this idea this would end in checkmate
and the white queen coming in trapping
the black king so uh to go back to the
current position yes simon as you
mentioned taking with this h pawn
completely opens up this line oh yeah
but the rule in the grunge field is if
you can take with this pawn you should
you always want to capture towards the
center
but the other option capturing away from
the center is safer here because at
least this pawn acts as a guardian
however now this black king later on
this diagonal
is going to be very very weak for
example if
let's say we make a move suddenly the
white bishop might land on this diagonal
and he has i can't believe he's done
that what a
brave or
fool hardy i i i mean tinderbox right
you know he's just waiting for ding to
strike a match
what about this line now the the open h
line
okay we definitely have fire in this
game yeah yeah but from both sides from
both players we should mention
ding trying to light the fire but major
of allowing him to and yeah if you could
somehow swap the queen and bishop round
if you could swap their places it's just
going to bend and change maybe we could
show why that bishop idea doesn't work
as well here so white would like to play
this outrageous bishop move but now that
the knight is there the knight can take
that bishop and if we move the queen in
well you can move the bishop to
any square pretty much but here and the
knight does a great job of defending the
czech mate i mean saying that ideas like
this are always there
and they they're very dangerous with the
queen and rook lined up on the open file
so it's something you have to watch out
for i just got to mention this rhyme
simon knight on f8 there is no mate so
it's a great defensive uh square so
that's why um i think mama durov is
pretty confident i'm not sure he should
be but he's pretty confident in his
defensive chances because his knight is
within range of its uh key defensive
square still ding has to be very
creative to break through and deliver
checkmate it feels like it's close but
not yet so we definitely have fire in
this game we definitely have fire in the
quarterfinals all of the matches ended
with decided games in the first round
eventually as you can see pragnando was
able to win game one against weiyi
so we do have
four players in the lead in their
quarter-final
matches could be a short day if they all
decided in three games because that is
possible best out of four rapid games
and uh potentially though also
high breaks with blitz and armageddon
but
four players will have to make comebacks
to make that happen
what a start to the knockout stage i
know it's unbelievable actually i have
to say one thing about pragananda you
know at the oslo esports he kind of made
it a habit to either win a match in
three games or lose it wasn't that
strange all of his matches after three
games eight days and uh oh what was it
no sorry seven days and every single one
of them decided in the minimum time
possible i mean that shows he's either
attacking very well or he's not
defending yeah so well most of those
matches he did win as well and that must
be a sign he is a very fighting player
yes yeah you always are when you're
young but him especially pregnant he
doesn't necessarily show in attacking
all out but as we saw in his last win i
mean it took him more than an hour to
win he's happy to grind things out and
squeeze every point um out of an end
game so yeah pregnant starting well wow
and whilst
deng is thinking about how to continue
his attack
well we have two competitions today we
have a selfie competition for some
really awesome prizes of some signed
goodies from anish giri and we also have
a quiz of the day where we're asking
what is your goal in chess chess ball
course is the prize there and for the
selfie competition i have to share with
you this really nice selfie from flowy
who says we're supposed to be studying
for upcoming maths exam which is
tomorrow by the way but we couldn't just
resist chess is in the air today they're
like balancing on a
playground equipment i think it's a
swing
thanks for keeping us company during
this stressful exam period such a cool
picture you know they're balancing on
things and they're playing chess above
the swing i'm very impressed i'm very
impressed with their dexterity i mean
it's such a cool photo as well so thanks
for watching flowey and uh yeah and good
luck on the exactly yes of course good
luck and abhishek says that they are
doing the dishes tonight to make up to
their upset wife
watching the chesapore marsh masters
alongside shh don't tell her about it we
won't we definitely won't and a big
hello to you and your wife and i hope
you enjoy hope you can finish doing the
dishes quickly yes
and well we have a solution from ding
who's decided that
all he needs to do is develop his light
square bishop potentially inviting more
pieces into the attack
yep so white's bishop defends the key
central pawn as well uh black slight
square bishop was hitting the white pawn
on e4 white defends it
i don't think white's intention is to
castle the white king if you castle the
white king then you lose your uh rook's
kind of open line oh so he's just not
gonna castle him at the king wants to
castle no i think he just wants to
create a safe square for the white king
to slide across to um the white rook is
perfect where it is yes the white king
is not entirely safe but it's better
having the white rook on the open line
if possible and meanwhile mamadoura
continues with his counter play on this
queen side but it is the wrong half of
the board and the computer hates it yeah
i'm not sure why it hates it to be
honest it looks like one of the most
natural moves in the position the
manager of playing instantly trying to
put pressure on the clock could you step
up with your king
i yeah i was also thinking the queen
could just now start maneuvering around
as in you couldn't do that last move
because the white king doesn't have a
square but now maybe maybe the queen can
start his journey towards the king side
but yeah stepping up with the kings very
interesting as well yeah interesting
maybe we can show this uh to the viewers
because
right now black is kind of threatening
this pawn with his own pawn and with the
bishop uh whoops there we go the bishop
in the corner but uh yeah you can ignore
it why
and he's played it yeah as he played it
yeah this this i think this is the idea
of white's last move
uh because if the black bishop now comes
in with czech uh well first of all you
can think about taking it certainly but
you can also just put your king where
the where the bishop was
which is a pretty safe square i think
and uh
if that white queen gets to the open
harry file
it is surely going to be a an absolute i
mean just
just looks like checkmate basically i
mean this just looks like a very
nice demonstration how to use the h pawn
to attack at the moment also the white
knight coming in to attack this pawn uh
yup it looks
almost disastrous for black and in the
current position after the white queen
did indeed leap forward um majority's
just trying to create chaos
just look at the clock time for
mahajarov it's one of the craziest
wildest positions you will ever see he's
barely spent any time and he's thrown
this pawn forward to attack the white
bishop firstly the question is what
happens if this pawn is captured i don't
think ding will even bother with that it
would be so tempting to throw the knight
into the position maybe simon you
mentioned the white queen sliding across
so many tempting moves and it's all
about whether the black king is going to
survive i don't think it will but still
some calculation needs to be done and uh
yeah i was going to say earlier why
bother defending bishops pawns when
uh when you're on the attack he does
keep his bishop safe take this pawn and
uh now i guess mamjarov's idea giving up
that pawn for black is that he can swing
his rook across at least create an open
line uh some targets here for the black
rook
how is ding gonna meet this if the rook
does slide across
that is the key question
is he gonna just gonna drop his bishop
back maybe and again simon's idea um if
the bishop takes his pawn just run away
with his king to safety
ken this is one option can he uh try to
throw some fuel onto the fire and just
uh move his knight to attack yeah maybe
the bishop goes there as well i'm just
thinking yeah um
maybe the white bishop could also slide
back uh with the idea that yes you're
giving up a piece but uh i know simon
wants to get rid of the black bishop
potentially yeah queen h4 queen across
so very close to just being checkmate
with the bishop coming into e7 yeah um
one of these moves the czech and this
king at some point you can check it with
your bishop still some work to be done
here maybe bishop h6 is just just game
over there yeah
actually you're right simon the king has
no escape squares so you break down the
only defender you distract it away and
then this is trackmate i love your idea
simon i mean i just think the white pawn
in the middle of the board is
such a good pawn as well i mean it's
that you've got the king side attack but
you've got this d pawn which stops
black's king coming to the middle
it's just another attacking unit so uh
it just looks very natural to get the
queen over get on the dark squares just
play brutal don't waste any time don't
move the attack piece uh unless you have
to why bother moving it and go for check
mate
if you can i mean with that logic simon
if you want to bring your queen across
anyway then maybe you don't even need to
okay he does jump forward with the
knight also looks very tempting of
course but so checkmate in one
threatened if the white queen can take
this pawn it's defended by this knight
and the black king is trapped so how do
you stop this if the black knight jumps
into the center
okay this bishop blocks if the black
knight jumps in you can distract the
black knight by pushing your pawn
forward attacking these two rooks and if
the black knight takes this pawn
checkmate but the evaluation bar really
doesn't like what ding has done and in
the current position
attack this pawn attacked
mamajora simply blocked it he brought
his bishop forward and maybe the reason
is because now it's harder to move your
bishop out the way to get your queen
across this bishop is in the way of the
open file
uh maybe the white knight as well in the
way of the bishop the bishop in the way
of the queen
maybe it was a bit clumsy yeah no it was
a nice uh
i think he only saw the line that you
kind of indicated with the decoy of the
night but uh this move somehow
keeps it all together for black these
two pieces key defensive pieces can ding
distract them get them away
and uh i also have to share with you a
kind of very curious goal that uh our
guest on day two has uh carl portman
he's hello carl
he says that my dream in a chess game is
to castle giving instant checkmate have
any of us on the panel done that
no
i've seen some streamers do it online um
but
i don't think i've ever achieved it my
proudest castling moment was castling
queenside on move 37 my opponent
resigned a few moves later but uh
that's the latest checkmate but it
wasn't uh latest castling but it wasn't
checkmate oh
simon i'd love to same as carl um i
would love to castle and give chet mate
i mean like uh i was quite fine i
remember there was a very famous game i
think it was laska or someone who who uh
gave checkmate by moving his king
but he could have castled and given
checkmate and i'm just like why didn't
you castle and give chet mate why did
you move the king
with some taking on h7 i think i think
it was alaska walked to gdp yeah and he
didn't castle and give checkmate and
it's like ah and have you done it or
like no i i hadn't even thought about it
actually it hadn't been a thing in my
mind so ah something to do actually
would that be like a checklist a little
bit hard to actually discover because
it's just so strange it would be very
hard to achieve i think yeah i mean like
there are a couple of cases of it uh but
it's extremely rare extremely rare
probably one in a million right yeah
literally one in a million yeah that
occurs maybe even more yeah
so yeah so normally you castle your king
early so you kind of lose that option
yeah normally you've already moved your
king or your rook earlier in the game
yeah so like move 37 before you castled
in that game yeah that was against uh
john ludwig hammer ah shout out to
hammer on tvt yeah and uh yeah i managed
to win that game nice yeah he kind of
jumped back in his chair when i castled
he probably forgot it was still legal at
that point move 37 is quite late and it
was an end game it was just kings and
rooks on the board and i just castled
and smiled at him and
wow
but uh okay meanwhile the white bishop
that was under attack it has taken
a step back
that feels like a step in the wrong
direction maybe sorry has gone over to
shakira on the other side i have to say
and the clock is definitely in his favor
there's a very famous case actually of
magnus carlsen castling against i think
sergey kariakin um and and just it was
the winning move it was a really it was
a really weird thing where sergey had a
piece on the edge of you know but anyway
if we can find that example at some
point it's really worth showing maybe
one of our viewers can tweet in that
game yeah
it's really nice and uh back to the game
it it black black's created loads of
counter play here loads of counter play
um and what's white actually doing now
can white
get that queen over now that white
knight though we'll need to take a step
back at some point the white knight is
just in the way and ding making a bit of
a face on the camera look at the clock
times four minutes now for ding thirteen
minutes for mahadaya
samajarov clearly taking risks here he
doesn't really care about the position
he's just trying to put pressure on the
clock so i mean one one idea here if i
if i was white i mean there's no time to
back down now as soon as you start
playing defensive moves here as white
you're basically going the wrong way so
can i go queen over to h4 and my idea is
to go bishop into in front of the black
king this is like the the first kind of
idea you think of the most brutal way
you can but does that even work maybe it
doesn't even work so for example or it
doesn't even if that doesn't work i'm
not sure yeah
yeah um i'm not sure what black can play
here i mean there's so many moves one
move i want to play for black is to kind
of cut off the white king's escape and
uh for example if you jump in with your
bishop i'm the first to check you look
at that i mean that is that's that's
checkmate with a pawn
we know what that's called don't we
you can tell us porn power
it has a name i know i've forgotten it
now so what was it with david
oh what's that is it is david slayer
thinking about it this is actually a big
threat or it was in the position because
uh this pawn push discovered check traps
the white king in the center of the
board that's why ding
maybe he wants to go for simon's idea or
something similar but he knew this white
king is actually immortal danger in the
center and remember he doesn't want to
castle because then the white rook is no
longer on this beautiful h file instead
he wants to run away i can't let charlie
be the porn star can you though so yeah
that would be really bad so charlie the
seaport yeah yeah let's see
down but so now the pawn pushing is no
longer a discovered check on this square
the white king is just one move away
from complete safety
so is white in trouble maybe i mean if
white attackers black's got the attack
now maybe so uh it could be uh
it could be really difficult yeah the
question is what next for black um for
example you could offer a trade of
queens in the center of the board that's
the first thing that comes to my mind
just because i'm a scaredy cat and i'm
worried about the defense of the black
king if the queens disappear black is
just safe black is probably winning but
uh again it just depends on the kind of
ferocity and the strength of white's
attack the white queen will slide across
maybe black can grab this pawn but it
depends whether you can kind of get this
bishop out of the way and deliver a
checkmate somehow
i don't see it to be honest at the
moment i don't see how you break through
but
it's still double-edged and we'll see
the evaluation bar swing swing swing
it's that kind of position um no human
can navigate these complications
perfectly
it's kind of an imperfect uh
type of beauty that we're looking for
here and hopefully we'll see a checkmate
on the board it's quite likely at this
point he's gone for it
makes sense to try to exchange queens
off because uh that c pawn could just
win win the game goodnight as we've seen
in some variations as well so
um
it just looks like white the energy and
white's attack has kind of gone with the
counter play and that night move that
one night move just lost more control
for ding it looks so it looks so logical
as well just to throw the knight in and
threaten checkmate but i'm a little bit
surprised he did it still saying that
because black only had one defense
really and that was moving the bishop to
block the knight and
then ding slowed down so why didn't he
slow down before
playing the night into that square is a
bit strange
i think it just happens when you see one
attractive line you kind of get swayed
into that and then you forget about
the normal developing move and okay the
queens are off the board more checkmates
no
but okay
ding still has a very powerful past pawn
yeah i've got to disagree as well
juventus earlier i think ding is too
good to just look for one move threats i
think he was just flustered
psychologically by the clock times by
the practical i mean mahmoud playing
instantly every move bang bang bang
maybe ding assumed mahmoud was still in
preparation or something um and then he
just
yeah he lost his attack and now he is
the one fighting for the draw wow
yeah it's actually level material after
all of those fireworks uh but the reason
we think uh black is in charge here is
black's far advanced pawn is pretty
strong the white king may be slightly
open on some diagonals white's far
advanced pawn is likely to drop at some
point soon
and also the clock times and it's all
about the clock almost 10 minutes up for
mamadiaro he is thinking right now he
has to make a comeback because ding did
win the first game and uh in the other
matches pragnanda is in the lead against
huayi they are now playing game two bar
in the middle
anish giri is in the lead winning game
one against arianzo aryan with the white
pieces here in game two fighting for a
win and david anton the bar is slightly
over to his side in game two against
magnus magnus did win game one and that
one and remember best out of four rapid
games to decide of each of those
quarterfinal
matches if um
magnus does win
that match he will
meet the winner of this match in the
semi-finals
oh yeah carlson against ding world
number one versus number two maybe but
mama durov and david anton will have
something to say about that absolutely
and okay my drawer thinking for a while
black's pawn is under threat from the
two white rooks both the white's rooks
now
uh eyeing up the c3 pawn okay he doesn't
try and defend it he just moves his own
rook across trying to deal with white's
pawn so is that pawn now dropping yeah
we could see a trade of both of those
very far advanced pawns black c3 pawn
white d-pawn
but you know david um black white has to
be slightly careful because i'm just
looking at that piece on the
bishop on the h6 and it doesn't have too
many squares
and my my spider sentences are telling
me well you know maybe the knight can
come and attack the bishop and for
example if we do see white get greedy
and gobble up
this piece then the black knight can
move hitting this bishop and also
hitting this rook
it's still very complicated i mean for
example the white rook could swing back
this way put some pressure against the
black bishop but it does feel oh
actually here there's a night fork
uh yeah looking for checks in every
position
we all fall foul and we will forget
about that so yeah you're right ivanka
maybe a bit of a trap in the position if
white can't go safely and grab this pawn
and his own pawn is just dropping on the
next move and
it's definitely ding with his backs to
the wall here i was i wasn't sure why um
ding didn't play f4 last move there
might be a reason but can i'd love to
get my pawns guarded in the center of
the board so can i just play f4 here
let's say your knight does move i mean
there's other options and now if i can
play my other pawn this is like the
ideal setup if i can get this as white
i'd be like i must be winning now you
know this this this defends everything
and attacks so so maybe maybe this is
the way to play maybe this is keep going
forwards yeah it's i mean it's very
risky but it's very tempting and it
could well be very strong as you
mentioned simon he needs to play
something though ding down at one minute
and we're expecting this pawn push
because simply what else kick away the
knight you do have to worry about maybe
black's bishop coming to the side of the
board with a check you have to worry
about um a few other things here for
example the night going and capturing
this bishop immediately lots to
calculate but ding has to move one
minute now against 10.
he's in big trouble in practical terms
he needs to find the right moves though
to stay on the board yeah i think and
when you go into this kind of thing as
well it's like you know the energy it's
like so critical in some positions you
can maneuver around a lot slower but
when you get to something like this
every half a tempo
makes the world of difference so
creating frets becomes so much more
important than when you have a lock
structure so f4 seems very logical it
creates a threat it keeps the tempo
going uh so i'd be amazed what's his
time you see the 30 seconds okay
okay it just dropped to zero i think
that's a
that's not quite correct i think he
still has a few seconds here ding um
what is happening has he frozen he needs
to make a move he needs to push report
he needs to do something
but he's just flustered
he's not comfortable is he what is his
time i mean do we has he lost on time
just before this happened uh he had
around 30 seconds left so i think he
still has a few seconds but he needs to
move in the next few moments he needs to
make a move
and he's looking very flustered yeah he
was looking up to the clock a few
moments ago his eyes darting to one side
is he still not moving it must be
technically some technical issues
because if he gets disconnected under 30
seconds i think he loses the game he
does yeah but he you can see from the
camera
or maybe
because it looks like he's thinking
about the game
yeah right isn't it yeah so it looks
like he has more than 30 seconds but we
did see something on mondial's face
there yeah look at that
he's still playing yeah yeah he
definitely brought up another screen
there we saw the light change on my
majora's face so maybe he's asking the
arbiter you know what's happened my
opponent's disconnected or the move
hasn't come through
we can still see him on the camera
though he's interested sometimes this
happens you know that the webcam
yeah somehow stays on but the internet
connection right
but you probably wouldn't be looking
this car would you if you just
disconnected surely i mean he's still
looking like he's concentrating on the
game
sometimes on online i've made the move
and i've assuming my opponent's thinking
and next thing it's like oh you're lost
on time so maybe he's made the move
waiting for majirao to move but he's
lost
possibly
wow this is dramatic what is happening
with dingley ran is he thinking about a
move or is he looking over a game that
he has lost on time or on technical
issues it would be such a shame for the
game to end in this way there's still
many many twists and turns ahead on the
board at least and it's just all about
the clock all about the internet
connection i mean it would be a pity
because this is such an interesting
position and it's been such a great game
for it to end this way i really hope
that doesn't happen here there is
history here uh on the magnus carlson
chess tour two years ago ding did lose
one game in the balance by disconnection
and uh we saw magnus win a fair play
award by giving back the next game
giving uh just resigning after a few
moves because he didn't want to win in
that way
i mean i think here i it would be let's
say hypothetically that ding has lost on
time i don't think as if you're in
manijaro's position you'd want to give
the next game back because it's probably
the best position mama jarvis got all
game yeah so it's like oh hang on a
minute i wanted to win this position
anyway
it's a bit it depends but uh we're just
waiting to see what's going on at the
moment uh because mama jaroff now is not
looking at the screen anymore but ding
is so it's really peculiar uh the
situation here maybe ding has been in
contact with the arbiter he knows that
they'll try and reset the game reset the
times reset everything and he's trying
to use these few moments to study the
board but majority of just looking away
and i think it's very comfortable i
don't know i'm just looking at the body
language and i'm thinking ding is
oblivious yeah i think i think he's
waiting for majora to move baby i think
he's just made his move and he's waiting
for him like you say and mama jaffe was
like hey what's happening he's typing
now he just typed something ding to the
arbiter oh
we are waiting for updates on what is
going on is this still this game still
being played has ding lost on time due
to technical issues
are they still playing what's happening
what is happening it's gonna be so hard
to refocus on the game okay he has made
a move so it looks like there was a
disconnection but he's been given his
time back he's at 36 seconds
still not a lot of time but it's your
move slimy
i think it had to be played right this
move and uh uh what's the rule then if
you disconnect under 30 seconds then you
uh then you have 30 no you have 30
seconds to reconnect and if you don't
manage to reconnect right so you could
have done it with a couple of seconds
there or you know yeah
yeah but it's kind of kind of like if
you don't manage to
weaken it in 30 seconds the problem is
it takes you two minutes you only lose
30 seconds when you we join the game and
if you have less that's it okay
don't have it looks like it's game on
anyway which is uh which is good yeah
but this must have been oh you've been
looking at ding's body language he's not
comfortable at all
he's i mean the position as well is
super complicated um it's just about
whether he can brush that off we did see
him focusing though maybe having that
extra minute or two during that kind of
uh during that
disconnection maybe it's going to help
him remember some really dirty tricks uh
being played in in one tournament i was
playing it as a rapid play tournament
and i had to change the rules because
this so it used to be if you made an
illegal move
then your opponent gets time added to
their clock and i saw i saw this one guy
and he was like in a very tense game at
the top of the tournament and
he was trying to calculate we only had
about 30 seconds left so he made an
illegal move and then you have to wait
until the arbiter comes over the arbiter
then has to add time to the opponent's
clock and then you start you take the
move back and you start the clock again
so while the arbiter was coming over and
doing this he was just like
he was using that time to get an extra
30 seconds four
and uh you know that actually helped him
just calculate the position so it's uh
quite quite see that a few times as well
yeah it's quite a dirty rule i mean
right to have that kind of mindset you
know i i'm not thinking about that when
i'm playing chess i'm not thinking about
how i can bend the rules
not at all i'm just thinking about how i
can survive
but i also remember in the same
tournament around before i was i was
playing someone and this is the weirdest
thing that's ever happened to me
i was like a queen and a piece down but
you had about 30 seconds left but he was
so nervous he couldn't move his piece so
he was trying to move i put him in check
with like my remaining piece and he's
getting the king and it was it was like
this and he couldn't he literally
couldn't put the king down because he
was shaking so much
it you kind of do feel sorry for him but
not really because you want to win
and then he put the king down he put it
in into check so he did an illegal move
so the arbiters came over they gave me
the extra time they put the position
back and you know what he did so they he
had to replayed it so he again he picked
the king up again and he did the same
move again
he put it into check again two times in
a row and it's like he's just completely
mentally collapsed you know he just
couldn't handle the pressure because he
was winning and it would have been quite
a good victory for him there's quite a
lot of people watching and he just
couldn't move the pieces
his hands were all over the place that's
a stressful stressful i took the win
anyway you know so
it's a brutal game you know so uh but um
yeah i know it's very peculiar scenario
but yeah you do feel sorry for him but
uh yeah i mean
nowadays the second illegal move is a
defeat right yes so yeah so if you make
two illegal the first one you just your
opponent gets a bit more time and you
get kind of a informal warning second
one game over okay all the little
children know this rule actually
and they probably know when it was
introduced because i don't know but uh
you know they they're there oh a legal
move arbiter up to come over yeah
have been on record
maybe for rapping and blitz is it just
one a legal move i think it's one
actually one yeah for a long play i
think it's two for wrapping a blitz
maybe to stop those
instances where you can actually play an
illegal move on purpose to gain more
time which people do you know i mean i
don't think anyone here would do that
but i know there's there's some less
unscrupulous characters out there
i remember there were some dirty tricks
like one that i heard that used to be
done by a certain nation i would be they
will be nameless was that when your
opponent was in time troubles they would
do this with their pen they would like
have this
oh really yeah and it was just too yeah
it would just be like there to stress
you out even more right yeah yeah i
didn't even really that's really dirty
isn't it
grab that pen and start just like come
on come on come on come on
yeah
make a move i really want to know the
nation now so they were told to do this
by their trader they were taught these
dirty tricks
wow okay i mean
you have to tell me afterwards
yeah okay yeah lots of dirty tricks out
there lots of gamesmanship as we call it
but okay nothing dirty going on in this
game ding is back in uh
he's back he's connected and okay
critical moment the bishop slides over
giving the white king a check and whoa
ding goes in this direction looking into
some tracks walking into the line of
fire the black knight can jump in now
with a check simon you're shocked
i i expected the king to go the other
way where it looks a lot safer because
this invites
um we can maybe just show this it
invites the black knight to come in with
a fork with a big check here and
i guess the idea is is really nice you
want to take this night off and after
the bishop comes in we now get this pawn
structure which looks actually still at
beautiful for white absolutely beautiful
these pawns controlling things and ding
loves the initiative he loves uh
exchange sacrifices and so so this is
what he's trying to do he's at all costs
trying to get the initiative i guess
this is the idea but why didn't he go
the other way with the king i'm i'm not
entirely sure good question i love this
idea i mean it looks absolutely from a
visual point of view it looks beautiful
get those pawns going and uh i mean what
use is the extra rook if it's uh
lumbered behind black white's past porn
okay to just go back and show the white
king it did indeed centralize and i
think we're heading in this direction um
and the position you may know your bank
is yeah what use is this black rook just
staring at a well fortified pawn
and for example the variation we could
continue it the black bishop under
threat doesn't really want to trade
itself off for just a night but here i
think there are direct tactics there
might even be ideas for example giving
up white bishop for a pawn and really
breaking things open and this is the
type of thing ding is calculating with
only his 40 seconds left after a check
another fork we're gonna see a weird
weird scenario where white has three big
very strong pawns against black's bishop
and
who knows which is better who knows who
hurts who has the advantage here and uh
probably a draw probably well yeah but
we'd we'd all probably rather be white
though in this position surely i mean
going back to that one yeah this
position i mean or you know even with
the move play but you know if black does
go for the exchange i'm sure it's much
more fun having the initiative having
that pawn structure i mean no one here
would want to be black and you could
after the connect four next move just
push your pawn forward connect four did
someone tell me you were good at connect
four is that uh
don't think it's me i'm terrible
okay i'm okay
are you yeah but i mean you you work it
out you know that's the problem
soon it becomes like i remember what i
remember working out nuts and crosses
that's about as far as i got you know
with those ones yeah good work
cheers well chuckling
he is finally spending a lot of time
ticking down to three minutes now the
drama is definitely going on in the
quarter finals bar all the way over to
prague side in game two he could be
about to go up by two points against wei
and the bar also all the way over to a
niche geary side in game two he could be
about to take
a lead by two points
and here we do have some moves we do
have some moves and okay that variation
has happened and
black has just given up a piece what is
this for mamadirov giving away his
bishop the black dart squad bishop
i'm trying to understand why it's porn
now i understand this white pawn train
are really strong but go and grab a
piece i mean if anyone's up for the
craziness challenge it's mamba jaroff
and he's kind of proven that here and
and white doesn't want to take that
bishop because it will ruin those lovely
pawns he prefers those pawns it reminds
me of famous uh this game pogolivsky did
with his some crazy por porn rook
sacrifice in the bot finnick going a bit
deep there but it's the same idea those
pawns are actually worth more than a
piece and what's this another great
another weird move these guys are
maniacs and they are really surprising
each other i think on every single turn
white's just given a pawn away to
deflect this black bishop and now this
very strong black pawn on the c2 square
is too far advanced you have to get rid
of it
no
he doesn't even go for this again
they've surprised us on every move and
surely now okay the white knight left
back attacking black's bishop surely now
you have to get rid of this black pawn
before it's too late incredible position
isn't it incredible
both players are just playing
otherworldly chess i mean that's the
only way you can describe it i mean it's
really um
just strange moves
i mean i don't even know what to say
about it i'm going to ask her kind of go
bringing it back to the position i mean
white has to get rid of that pawn
with the wreck or the bishop i think
you've got to keep the rope that's what
my vibe is as well but then on the other
hand i'm a little bit worried that
black's work is also going to get active
and i mean i'm still looking for
checkmate here if i'm white i still want
to get my rook to the open h file and
check mate i mean this is one thing i
really you know
under 10 seconds though for ding does he
keep the rook on the board how does he
keep the rook on the board that is the
problem i mean bishop if he goes bishop
two seconds one second has he moved oh
he's okay he's going he's he's he's not
taking that pawn no he's trying to trade
off the dark square bishops he wants to
get the white knight into the f6 square
okay we'll see a trade white's going to
recapture i think with his pawn
uh there we go so he has broken his pawn
structure but the white knight is
threatening to leap into the f6 square
with the deadly check black's king has
to move at some point i mean one thing
that's very handy for white for black
here is that the rook goes into the
corner black can say can push the pawn
queen and divert that rook so uh
so i think i think baba jaros over the
worst i mean yeah
i think he's waiting
just to show just to show simon's really
important uh point there the rook coming
across this actually threatens to come
up and uh at least force a draw with uh
with a series of checks against the
black king but black can trade a set of
rooks here by pushing his pawn he
doesn't even need to to be honest he can
maybe even bring his rook across
challenge for the open file and
i think ding's in big big trouble he's
trying now instead of bringing his rook
across instead of bringing the white
rook he's trying to push his pawn
forward he's hoping that the black rook
lands on a bad square and that there
might be a night fork a check and
hitting this rook at the same time but i
think if you choose any other square for
black this isn't actually a threat even
because this white pawn is pinned
but yeah for example if you move your
rook to a good square
is that just game over is that winning
yeah yeah and it's it's it's because of
that trick that you highlighted as soon
as the white rook moves well the pawn
promotes itself yeah and uh for example
here you could see oh white gets a rook
but suddenly black makes a new queen and
uh checkmate is that chart the sea pawns
been absolutely was i don't know if it
was the b pawn i think it started as a b
pawn as being the star of the show but i
i have to say like this is such brave
play throughout by mahmoud you know
medaroff here because uh he played this
opening it was probably a bit dodgy but
fortune has certainly favored the brave
in this game okay he does play this move
but um just as i was talking there i did
notice maybe a small trick
um that i had missed so after the white
rook comes across now if black does
bring his rook across there is a nasty
check
actually this doesn't work either you
just take with the black rook um maybe a
night check as well it's still a bit
complicated hitting the black king
in the current position maybe we can see
the stockfish uh suggestions here for
moves because what does black do this is
actually a bit of a threat now and okay
there are two winning moves and both of
them oh sorry
how many times you get to get a bishop
you know and why is that why is that
stronger than getting a queen
okay
we do see that move simon we do see a
promotion to a queen in the end and
after a set of trades here the black
king coming back this pawn is about to
get rounded up and uh in the current
position black is winning because his
rook can get active this pawn is dealt
with by the black king and now his rook
is going to enter the game and should be
winning now for black still some work to
do though
wow what a game
what a game by mamadiar of
yeah i mean
let's not write a ding off yet because
there's been so many kind of
uh yeah it's been a roller coaster and
there's been so many twists and turns
but the clocks though thing is under the
minute mamjaro still has more than two
minutes on the clock and the bar is
loving it for him to make a comeback in
the match
yeah
and uh yeah he will be making a comeback
as long as he can either get the black
rook active and or get rid of white's
very far advanced pawn so i think the
black bishop as well could maybe go on a
journey at some point to go and remove
white's d7 pawn from the board
maybe some chances i'm imagining the
white king going after black's a pawn
that lonely pawn on the side of the wood
if white's king can run and kind of
sprint over grab that pawn then white
doesn't have a potential passport of his
own
some calculation to be done for the
azari and aneesh giri he has now also
won game two with the black pieces
against aryanthari so that means anish
in game three then starting in 15
minutes he will only need a draw that's
going to be a must-win situation for
aryan with the black pieces it's looking
really good for a niche still unbeaten
in the tournament
yeah yeah didn't lose a single game in
the preliminaries he eventually also won
the preliminaries
he must be closing in on 2800 in the
tour ratings point because he was 27 77
going into today and now he's won two
games in a row
and arya was 27 10. yeah yeah impressive
from uh anishigiri i will check with tai
man at the moment yes
and uh okay what is my majora thinking
about he's about to drop under one
minute
i don't see where the black bishop moves
the black king is on its ideal square
you have to move the black rook i was
going to say but that's a really deep
one
sophisticated move black's pawn pushing
to a light square
slightly surprised i guess black's idea
is to bring his bishop down to the f1
square and protect black's
pawn far far away
but now the white knight re-roots it's
not this is not over i don't think
because
that that pawn that white's got is
incredibly strong and i think ding's
maneuver of bringing the knight out out
of there it gives it uh well uh many
more potential
places to go to this this is this is to
my eyes is still game on actually i
don't think it's over at all i really
don't like this bishop maneuver it just
i think you're just getting together
getting the rook out david like you said
would just seem so much more more
natural right so you would have gone
behind attacked all the white pawns but
okay now mama jaroff
okay this is really not clear anymore
who's winning here yeah look at that the
white a pawn is gonna start racing up
the board yeah i mean uh i i
i maybe prefer to be white here even i
mean much easier to play for white at
least you've got to get the rook out now
haven't you is there anything else you
can't take the pawn can you i mean
that's just yeah i was i was thinking
that
the black king probably has to
remaneuver itself over to the c7 square
so the king kind of controls some of its
the white king's uh
entries entry points and takes so long
though black needs to move the rook move
the black king around two three moves
but you have to you have to have to do
something yeah surely you have to get
the rook out now as you say yeah you
have to get the rook out but this is a
perfect scenario for ding because he
only has one plan push the white a pawn
up forward queen make it queen and it
the white pawn the white apron promotes
on a light square same color as your
bishop i mean i definitely prefer to be
white now i mean i i have to do some
calculations especially
yeah especially if neither side have
time to calculate it's easier to be
white okay finally i think belatedly the
black group enters the game and here we
go the pawn pushes lava jar of lower on
the clock now and he checks the black
king forward why does he do that helping
the white king sorry forward i don't
know why he's pushing the king up the
board there very strange decision and uh
and as you say it's just white's plan
with little time so easy push the a pawn
use the king use the bishop queen simple
black has to think how i got time to
take a pawn uh do i move the king around
like ivanka said i like that plan i
think that's a good a good try but
there's many more options that black has
to think of here so
he's under half a minute this has gone
horribly wrong at the end of this game
for mama jarov so far from my experience
with time trouble as well it's always
the one who hasn't been in time trouble
during the game as soon as they dropped
low on the clock they panic mahmoud has
had 10 minutes for most of this game
ding has been down playing at 30 seconds
the whole game pretty much so he's used
to it ding is in the zone he's in the
rhythm mamajarov clearly is in under
five seconds now wow
okay
he's gone for my plan but now i think
he's he's wasted time you know by giving
checks here
and now i do think my my plan is
unfortunately too slow how do you stop
those pawns
he's helping the white king forward the
kings
i mean like the white king now can move
forward it can choose two different
directions do you go to the c file do
you go to the a file go to the c file
okay then there might be a rook e4 maybe
you know you might be able to grab i
know that doesn't work either does it so
you're right entering now you're right
your van could just go here
yeah i don't think you can stop the
pawns
well the only way that i can see is that
the rook goes fine goes to the a line
you should have come here three four
moves ago yeah
the black rook it could have started
checking ages ago maybe queen now and
that's just maybe maybe queening is just
winning yeah there we go he gives up one
pawn to deflect the black king away and
now the black king cannot stop the entry
of the white king it's just game over
this game you can't stop the pawn uh the
bishop's going to block the bishop can
come in support the pawn blacks pawns
can't move because that won't pass on
look at ding yeah he smiles he sits back
and sips some water incredible game pure
panic from
uh yeah yeah i think i love those games
i mean just because they're so exciting
right i mean like the human right you
know to r is to hume to be human but we
should explain why white is winning now
black has to give up his rook for the
white pawn and the white bishop
all of black's pawn stand on the light
squares as well white bishop will
eventually win them and there we go we
have a result wow what a crazy game mama
yara he was almost about to make a
comeback in the match but it is another
win for
ding and that means in game three
starting in 15 minutes ting needs a draw
to be ready for semi-finals that's going
to be a must-win for